San Francisco may be the most welcoming
city in America if you happen to be an
illegal immigrant with the record of
violent felonies and if you are get
there right away we're not exaggerating
incidentally how crazy is San Francisco
sanctuary policy well so extreme that
one of its original supporters one of
its architects Angela Alioto wants to
change that policy having seen it in
action tomorrow voters have the chance
to nominate her for mayor it'll be an
interesting test not just for Alioto but
for San Francisco and the state of
California and this country frankly
enjoy all the other joins us tonight and
so thanks a lot for coming on I should
stipulate for our viewers you're a
liberal Democrat I don't think we agree
on really anything which I think gives
you credibility on this subject so
you're against the sanctuary policy as
it is now working why I'm against it
because when I wrote it in the early 90s
we did not include violent felonies and
they amended it in 2013 and 2016 to
include covering violent felonies
there's a matter of fact there's like a
three prong test that a violent felon
would have to go through in order for
them to call the ice and so I said to
the supervisor who did it supervisor
Campos I said yeah I'm not going to
agree to that because they did come to
me as the original author and asked me
you know do I agree with adding violent
felons I said of course I don't agree
with adding violent felons that's
ridiculous
the concept is to protect families the
concept was never to protect violent
felons so when I did this ordinance a
month ago there was quite a bit of
hysteria all of the supervisors and the
the mayor of the city and this and the
city attorney and the DA got on this the
iconic steps of San Francisco City Hall
and called me all sorts of names and
said this was outrageous that I would be
attacking the sanctuary law I am not
attacking the sanctuary law I'm
attacking violent felons they should not
be protected under the sanctuary law or
any other law in San Francisco because
as you said we become a you know let's
go to San Francisco would be safe and
the other night on the news it was very
interesting Tucker the other night on
the news one of the news people
mentioned
that there hadn't been anybody in the
county jails had been brought there in
over a year and a half and that's
because the standards too high well
that's not I mean so just tell us for
those of us who don't live in San
Francisco what's the thinking behind
wanting more violent felons who were
illegal aliens in your city how does
that improve the life of the city of San
Francisco Tucker I have asked every
single elected official who came out
against me in the middle of this mayor's
race by the way which was pretty
dramatic I've asked them why do you want
to protect violent felons and the answer
to that if they answer at all most of
them don't answer but the answer that
some of them gave me was that I'm
chipping away at the sanctuary law I
said I'm not chipping away at the
sanctuary law I wrote the law originally
it was to protect families I would know
what I was chipping away at the law and
I have to tell you something though I'm
running for mayor as you know and I meet
hundreds of people every day and one of
the first things the citizens of San
Francisco say to me is thank god you're
doing something about dangerous felons
everything I say I don't think I'm in
danger of swaying a single vote in the
Democratic primaries Cisco when I say
bless you for doing this and be I really
hope you prevail me I think this is a
test for your city I really do it's the
city in America I did we got and the
rest very excited we got titling summary
from the city attorney now interesting
thing about getting title and Joe Murray
from the city attorney is that he was
standing on the steps condemning me so
it's somewhat a conflict of interest
it's unbelievable if you get this I hope
you'll come back on to celebrate at
least this part of you're just angry
Angele iota thank you very much
absolutely thank